في حدث اليوم اين وصلت قضيه الناشطه
المصريه علي عبد الفتاح المعتقل نهايه
العام الماضي بتهمه نشر اخبار كاذبه ما
الذي يفضت اليه كل الجهود للافراج عنه
سعيد بان يكون معي من شرم الشيخ فيليب
لوثر ومدير الابحاث للشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا في منظمه العفو الدولي اهلا وسهلا
بك هل تعتقد ان هذه الجهود ودخول الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا على
الخط الى جانب المنظمات غير الحكوميه هذه
الجهود سا تفضي الى الافراج عن علاء عبد
الفتاح
طبعا نامل هذا
والمهم انه علاء عبد الفتاح هو في حاله
حرجه
يعني طبعا هو حاليا في اضراب عن التعام
وعيدا منذ يومين تراب عن الماء ااا
فالمهم انه كل هذه الجهود
يعني انه هن هناك نتيجه ايجابيه وهو
النتيجه الوحيده عنه يعني فورا واقول فورا
همم لانه لازم يحصل يعني قبل فوات الاوان
يعني هذا حاله حرجه حرجه جدا
طيب اريد ان افهم منك هل هناك تجاوب من
قبل السلطات المصريه هل مثلا مع منظمه
العفو الدوليه هناك رد على كل التساولات
التي تطرحونها منذ فتره طويله
ليس هناك اي الرد على الاقل اي رد مباشر
من السلطات المصريه لحد الان نحن
باستمرار مستمر نحاول ان نكاتب السلطات
المصريه همم لنضغط عليهم همم الافراج عن
علاء عبد الفاسي وطبعا يعني كل
المواعتقلين الاخرين يعني كل ما اعتقلين
تعصفا
والسجناء الرائي ولكن لحد الان ليس هناك
همم هي الرد سلبي ولا ايجابي طيب من هو
محادثكم في مصر باعتبار ان هناك اعتقالات
موجوده نتحدث عن العاب الفتاح ولكن يوجد
عدد كبير من المعتقلين يعني كيفيه التعاطي
مع وضع حقوق الانسان في مصر مع من يجري
انتم كما منظمه العفو الدوليه هل هي فقط
منظمات مجتمع مدني ولكن حتى منظمه المجتمع
المدني لا يحق لها ان تتحدث بكل الحريه
هذا صحيح طبعا يعني منذ
8 سنوات تقريبا المجتمع المدني في مصر تحت
قمع وحشي وفضيع
وهذا طبعا ازمه ازمه بالانسان في مصر ولكن
في نفس الوقت جئنا في لمصر في هذه الايام
للنقف متضامنين مع شؤرك كائنات مع
اصدقاءنا في المجتمع المدني في ال- ال-
المنظمات الحقوقيه همم في مواجهه هذا
القمر يعني وخصوصا نحن كم منظمه نقوم
بحملات على همم كل القيود على والمضايقات
على هذا المجتمع همم المجتمع المدني مثلا
كل عمليه الحظر من السفر التحفظ على
الاموال
التقيقات الجنائيه ضد المدا اين ننقل
الانسان
همم فهذا مهم جدا ولذلك همم نقف متضامنين
معهم اليوم
في سياق المؤتمر مناخي و و و بشكل مستمر
طيب عندما نرى مثلا الحكم الذي صدر بحق
علاء عبد الفتاح يعني خمس سنوات سجن بتهمه
نشر اخبار كاذبه لديكم فكر على الملف في
الاخبار الكاذبه ما نوعيه هذه الاخبار
الكاذبه هل هي مجرد انتقادات
للسلطه في مصر او النظام في مصر وصفت
باخبار كاذبه فتم الزاجبه في السجن ام
ماذا يعني
نعم بالضبط يعني
هذا هو التكما اييه يعني مستعمله يعني
بشكل
منهجي هنا في في مصر ضد المدافعين ضد
المنتقدين ضد المعارضين السياسيين همم
السلطات تستخدم تهمه الاخبار نشر الاخبار
الكاذبه فقط ل همم شرح ههه
ضد همم همم الرئيس السيسي ضد بالشكل اهم
همم العامه همم ضد همم ضد فعاليات او ضد
اليات النظام القضائي هنا في مصر همم يعني
همم
لدينا من لفات همم يعني كده عشرات من
الملفات او حتى مئات من الملفات مع نفس
نفس التهمه همم
وهذا التهمه وهذه وهذا هو ت- يعني توفى
كذبه همم ويعني ليس هناك اي اساس همم يعني
مشروع ليه لاعتق- ليه اعتقال على عبد
الفتاح هو سجين الرئيس طيب الغريب الامر
هو انك انت الان في شرم الشيخ تتحدث عن
وضعيه حقوق الانسان في مصر من شرم الشيخ
لو كنت مصريا على سبيل المثال هل كان
بامكانك ان تكون معي على المباشر وتحدث
بهذه الطريقه من شرم الشيخ هل فعلا يعني
وجودك كمسؤول في منظمه العفو الدوليه سمح
حلقه ان تكون في شرم الشيخ
يعني الكوب المؤتمر شرم الشيخ والمؤتر
المناخي اييي يعني السمح لنا بالدخول
اعتقد لمصر وايضا فتح الشباك يعني هو
الشباب
ليه بعض المدافعين الشجاع
الانسان في مصر ليه اا يتكلموا بشكل مباشر
بشكل واضح
ومفتوح
الانسان هنا في مصر ولكن ليس كانت كذلك
قبل همم المؤتمر وهمم يعني نخاف انه ليس
سيكون كذلك بعض همم المؤتمر
فهذا الشيء همم يعني فرصه همم فرصه قصير
فرصه قصيره الامن من اللازم
ان نحن همم
كمنظمه حقوقيه دوليه لنقل متدمن مع
المدافعين هنا في مصر طيب عاده في مثل هذه
المناسبات يسمح للمنظمات غير الحكوميه ان
تتظاهر على سبيل المثال وان تعرب عن رايه
رايها انا قرات على سبيل المثال ان ما حصل
في شرم الشيخ هو انا خصصت لكم يعني خصص
لكم مجال معين او فضاء معين للاعراب عن
رايكم في مكان محدد فقد ولكن لم تتمكن من
الاعراب عن عن رايكم مثل ما رد
نعم ايه نحن كمنظم نحن عندنا الفرصه
للوجود داخل
صلاه المؤتمر
فهذا يعني طبعا
يعني شكرا
اللي متحده ال المنضمين همم المنظمه يعني
لهذا المؤتمر ولكن خارج الصلاه همم صلاه
المؤتمر هناك فضاء اا معين من السلطات ليه
التظاهر ولكن هذا همم هذا الفضاء يعني من
اللازم تقدم همم تقدم همم يعني همم
طلب للرخصه 36 ساعه همم قبل همم قبل همم
قبل المظاهر
مفتوح فقط بين ساعه 10:00 والساعه 5:00
بعد الظهر وطبعا تحت المراقبه المست
المستمره فيعني اذا تريد ان تروح هناك
للمظاهره طبعا همم
ستكون على لوائح المعارضين السياسيين يعني
على طول يعني طبعا همم المدافعين عن حقوق
الانسان هنا في مصر همم لا يروحوا لهذا
الفضاء هذا هذا الفضاء يعني يسموه القفص
لانه همم مجوره يعني همم
يعني ليس هذا الفضاء يعني مفتوح بشكل ب ب
ب ب بشكل طيب بصراحه وسائل الاعلام
المصريه هل اقتربت منك على سبيل المثال
على الاقل محاوله فهم ما تريده منظمه
العفو الدوليه اما بما انك منظمه العفو
الدوليه لا لست ادري لماذا انقطع
طيب يبدو ان الخط انقطع وعاد تمام انقطع
للسوادره لماذا الشكر في الختام فيليب
لوثر سنحاول ان نواصل معه الحوار لو طبعا
عاده الا خطرتكم متواصل على فرانس 24
اه صحيح يعني
هي طبعا سناء سيف شقيقه علي عبد الفتاح
مدافع عنها حقوق الانسان ناشطه
يعني
موجوده هنا الان في في في شرم الشيخ كان
ممم يعني قدرت الدخول لمصر وتقدر الدخول
لشرم الشيخ والداخل صلاه المؤتمر وهذا مهم
همم طبعا لها يعني مقابله كثيره مع وسائل
الاعلام الدوليه في في في هذا المؤتمر همم
الان بالضبط يعني هي همم في همم في مناقشه
مع منظمه العفو الدوليه مع عائشه
همم
واخرين في همم في في صاله هنا في في
المؤتمر ليه طبعا لا تتكلم عن حاله همم
عائله همم طبعا همم حاله قضيه
اللي هي عبد الفتاح ولكن في نفس الوقت كان
في مضايقات همم في مؤتمر صحفي همم هذا
الصباح في صاله في المؤتمر من همم لسه
عارف يعني من من كنا هذا هؤلاء الاشخاص
وليكن الاشخاص كان لهم طبعا راي همم يعني
قريب من رايي همم الحكومه المصريه ولكن
كان من الممكن ان تتكلم عن حاله علي عبد
الفتاح وهمم يعني وتواصل فيه دعوه عن
افراج الافراج عنه وهذا مهم طبعا طيب
اهتمام لدى وسائل الاعلام المصريه خاصه
الرسميه بك انت وبحاله علي عبد الفتاح
ايضا
طبعا في مصر هناك همم
يعني هناك منافذ لبسائر اعلام كثيره
وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
والقريبه من من الدوله او لا تتكلم عن
الحاله او تتكلم عن القضيه همم يعني في
اطار همم
في اطار الخطاب الرسمي يعني ان هو همم
يعني كان يعني لا تهم ضد تهمم همم
والاخره ولكن هناك طبعا في نفس الوقت هناك
وسائل اعلام
مستقله همم
الصحفيين وال- والوسع الاعلام بشكل عام
همم المستقله
تتواجه ااا تواجه ااا القمل نفس القمه كم
مع المفروض على الحقوقيين المصريين يعني
مثلا حظر مواقع الانترنت لهذه الوسائل
الاعلام حضر من السفر التحقيقات القضائيه
الجنائيه والاخرين شكرا لك
من شرم الشيخ